Hi there!
I don’t know under which rock you live,
but Ms. Coffee Bean’s rock was hit by this
Tweet from Yann LeCun announcing a new paper
by Randall Balestriero, Jerome Pesenti and
himself explaining
why Deep Learning systems are actually extrapolating
and not interpolating like many other deep
learning scientists are saying.
We assume that this paper comes as a consequence
of the Twitter fight that was going on previously
were LeCun was claiming that deep learning
systems are extrapolating, but other well-known
researchers like Gary Marcus were explaining
why this is not the case.
At that time, I did not know what to think
about all this.
And now, after reading the paper I still can’t!
Ms. Coffee Bean here has an opinion, but will
she tell it?
So, in this video, we will explain the story
behind this question of interpolation versus
extrapolation in machine learning, what the
original arguments were, what the paper explains
and what people are responding to it.
First, two warnings: In this video, we will
show a lot of screenshots of text.
Feel free to pause and read, but we will summarize
everything.
As for the second warning: The tone of this
paper has quite a dose of vanity.
In some passages it seems like the authors
are explaining to us, kindergarten children
how the world works and that really, deep
learning models are extrapolating, while so
many of us were making the silly mistake of
thinking otherwise!
Which might be the case, I don’t know.
But ignoring the tone, the paper is written
well, explains things didactically, and has
the nice property of answering in exactly
the next sentence the questions I have been
asking myself while reading it!
But let’s forget about the paper for a bit
and focus on the origins of the whole discussion:
Yann LeCun reacted with a Tweet to Steven
Pinker who was praising a blog post explanation
of why neural networks are glorified curve
fitting algorithms and that they only interpolate
and therefore do not generalize.
And if we look into the blog post, this is
pretty much what the post says.
It reminds us that the Universal Approximation
Theorem states that a neural network with
one hidden layer can approximate any continuous
function under some assumptions.
So this means that the neural net takes a
super complicated function between input and
output but breaks it down into little pieces.
So this is glorified curve fitting right here,
but only in the data range that the model
has seen already.
The post gives the example of the Taylor series
which approximates a sine wave of let’s
say the temperature of a day when we do weather
forecasting.
There, the first polynomials of the Taylor
series model the range of the data really
well, but goes bananas outside of that range.
And a neural network might do the same, because
if there are no points outside of this range
during training, the loss will be zero when
approximating the training points perfectly
and the fitted curve models them perfectly.
So the blog post highlights that deep learning
does glorified curve fitting.
But Yann LeCun disagrees, he says that in
high dimensions, everything is extrapolation,
not interpolation.
Gary Marcus goes on to challenge LeCun and
brings examples as I have seen in my research
too,
that if one takes a neural network and teaches
it even numbers, the network cannot make sense
of odd numbers that would be in this case
extrapolation, because odd numbers were not
in the training set.
So you imagine how happy I was seeing that
Yann LeCun explains his viewpoint in this
new paper here.
And here with the definition of interpolation
is where it all starts:
The authors define that interpolation for
a sample occurs, when the sample belongs to
the convex hull of the existing set of the
examples.
The convex hull is that smallest convex polygon
enclosing the points such that any line you
draw from one border to another, stays inside
the hull.
So if we were take these blue points as training
set, draw the convex hull around it, we could
ask the interpolation versus extrapolation
question for a test point in the following
way:
hey, do you test point fall into the convex
hull of the training set?
If yes, the model is interpolating.
If you’re outside, then the model is extrapolating.
And what about alternative definitions of
interpolation?
Like the interpolative regime when the loss
on the training data is zero which the blog
post was talking about?
I do not know; they just discard this definition
and go on about the paper, even though it
seems like this definition of interpolation
was relevant for the blog post!
Anyway, let’s stick with the definition
of the authors for this moment.
They go on and reiterate theoretical results
and additionally show empirically that the
probability for a new point to fall into the
convex hull of the already sampled points,
quickly approaches zero when the dimensionality
of the space grows bigger.
And this makes sense, this is clear from the
curse of dimensionality,
because the space between stuff grows exponentially
as the number of dimensions increases.
But what about the intrinsic dimension of
the data?
The manifold hypothesis tells us that even
if the encoding of the data is D-dimensional,
the intrinsic dimension, that is the smallest
dimension to which we can reduce to without
losing information, can be much smaller than
D.
Well, the authors account for this by testing
on natural data that should lie on a lower
dimensional manifold and by data where the
intrinsic dimensionality was artificially
decreased.
The message?
Even though the data manifold is really low
dimensional, the experiments show that the
test data points do not fall into the convex
hull of the training data points, meaning
that the model extrapolates during testing.
The authors then conclude that extrapolation
does not guarantee generalization.
Because they have shown that what they see
here is technically extrapolation, but they
acknowledge that neural models are still very
limited and lack generalization, therefore
extrapolative capabilities do not amount to
generalization capabilities.
Ok, so this was the paper.
Now what to think about it?
Was everyone, including me and Ms. Coffee
Bean here, that were using the word “interpolation”,
wrong the whole time?
Well, let’s go back to the definition, where
the authors motivate it by reminding us that
it is used in other sciences in the same way.
But nonetheless, I do not think that this
is what people mean by “interpolation”
when referring to neural models.
You know, I have zero money in this game,
I am 100% willing to accept any definition
of this word and go on with it,
but let’s look at what Francois Chollet
tweeted in response to Yann LeCun.
Certainly in response to the arrogant tone
of the paper, he also responds in a very bold
fashion, calling their definition of “interpolation”
a “common beginner mistake”.
Because Francois Chollet goes on to explains
that the paper uses interpolation in the sense
of linear interpolation where all new points
can be sampled only from straight lines in
Euclidean space.
But the manifold the data lives on is curved,
and models do not learn linear interpolation,
but the manifold interpolation.
And by looking at this here, we can see how
the new point definitely falls of the convex
hull of those two points but is still a manifold
interpolation between the two.
So Ms. Coffee Bean, you’re telling me that
all this time renowned scientists were tweet-shouting
at each other because they were using the
same word but with different meanings?
The blog post seems to have meant the interpolative
regime when the loss is zero.
The paper of LeCun defines interpolation through
the convex hull.
Francois Chollet goes for manifold interpolation.
At least, this is what we understood from
these discussions...
We would also like to add this beautiful point
made in a Reddit discussion: that we never
expected models in the first place in the
first place to interpolate in the first place,
in the sense that things fall into the convex
hull of the training data.
Let’s suppose a case of linear classification
where we want to separate between two linearly
separable classes.
Well, we would still successfully classify
a point outside the convex hull, if it stays
on the right side of the decision boundary!
Just a thought for discriminative models,
because as far as I understand it, Francois
Chollet focuses more on the generative case
in his response.
Honestly, I am excited to see how this argument
continues.
What do you think about all of this?
I hope that Yann LeCun will come on the Machine
Learning Street Talk Podcast to tell us more
about the topic.
That was it for this video, see you next time!
Okay bye!